vous mettez à certains endroits vous
captez le soleil qui arrive à cet
endroit là ça m'aide pour beaucoup de
choses ça m'aide pour le placement de
certains meubles ça m'aide pour le
décider le genre de comment d'atmosphère
parce que le soleil va changer
l'atmosphère d'une pièce moi je trouve
c'est un des trucs les plus dingues que
j'ai vu dans ma vie c'est une blague
designer
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Éric brun Sanglard
[Applaudissements]
Eric brun sans l'arbre bonsoir vous êtes
ici ce soir pour un livre bouleversant
au-delà de ma nuit au presse de la
Renaissance dans lequel vous racontez
comment le jet setter que vous étiez le
directeur artistique dans la pub est
devenu aveugle après avoir été contaminé
par le virus du sida et comment malgré
ce handicap vous avez réussi à devenir
l'un des architectes d'intérieur les
plus renommés du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors Eric rebonsoir vous publiez au
prince de la Renaissance au-delà de ma
nuit un témoignage stupéfiant et
émouvant qui nous éclaire sur les
ressources insoupçonnables de l'être
humain et comment on peut arriver à
transformer sa maladie et son infirmité
en une destinée assez fabuleuse on va
voir ça alors Eric votre livre m'a
d'autant plus ému que j'ai habité
Chamonix et qu'enfant j'ai acheté mon
matériel de ski dans le magasin de votre
famille chez sandelar Sport moi aussi
j'ai mes construire des cabanes dans les
arbres moi aussi je rêvais d'ailleurs et
moi aussi mes insolences m'ont valu
d'être envoyé au pensionnat Saint-Michel
chez les curés Annecy
moi aussi j'ai connu les gestes douteux
des bons pairs sauf que j'ose pas en
parler
mais contrairement à vous j'ai pas connu
l'arrivée des filles à Saint Michel
c'était j'étais sur le côté j'observais
alors à 18 ans lors de vacances à DJERBA
une gitane vous dit en vous faisant les
lignes de la main vous allez déménager
sur un autre continent dans l'année et à
33 ans une partie de vous mourra comme
un sexe extraordinaire ça mais je me
disais toujours toute manière je
déménage nulle part je suis j'ai aucun
plan de déménager donc ça peut pas être
possible et un an plus tard vous êtes
aux États-Unis c'est là à ce moment là
où j'ai commencé à repenser très très
souvent à ce qu'elle m'avait dit sur les
33 ans c'est encore trouble alors là aux
États-Unis vous fréquentez les milliers
de la pub de la mode beaucoup de sexe à
cette époque beaucoup de drogues aussi
jusqu'au jour où vous découvrez que vous
êtes porteur du virus du sida vous en
parlez à vos à vos parents la
réprobation est terrible j'ose même pas
citer la phrase de votre frère qui est
d'une homophobie absolument
extraordinaire et vous comprenez qu'il
faudra vous relever tout seul que vous
pouvez compter sur personne Eric tout à
fait c'était un moment très très dur
parce que c'est vraiment un des moments
où je me sentir le plus solde de ma vie
en fin de compte voilà alors là vous
créez votre société de direction
artistique ça cartonne ça marche très
très bien
et là un jour en 1994 vous êtes en
voyage d'affaires en Suisse vous
conduisez une voiture à un moment vous
êtes gêné pour conduire vous avez une
tâche noire qui danse comme ça sur votre
rétine et quand vous allez voir un
toubib on vous annonce effectivement que
vous avez un cytomégalovirus ce qui veut
dire que vous allez perdre la vue et
mourir assez rapidement et maintenant ça
et d'une manière assez froide et je lui
dis qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse il
me dit bah il faut tout de suite que tu
ailles à l'hôpital et que tu commences
de la chimiothérapie voilà et là vous
vous rappelez ce cauchemar qui vous
hante depuis l'âge de 6 ans un homme en
noir avec une canne blanche
c'est incroyable quoi ça c'est
incroyable Dupont de plus que ma vue il
y avait pas du tout de problème j'ai
jamais eu de problème de vue à cette
époque là dans le bouquin vous racontez
vos traitements piqûres dans les yeux
qui vous font vous évanouir réveille en
vomissant
vous devenez de plus en plus aveugle
effectivement et à un moment il vous
reste deux anticorps alors que
d'habitude on en a entre 500 et 2000
avec beaucoup d'humour vous baptisé ces
deux anticorps Adam et Eve
c'est extraordinaire vous avez une
espèce d'énergie
vous avez une énergie et vous vous en
sortez de nouveau c'est votre vie c'est
vraiment les montagnes russes je sais
que c'est la philosophie que j'aime ma
vie c'est-à-dire que faut avoir une
certaine foi intérieure sans savoir sans
comprendre et d'aller devant alors voilà
là vous cherchez du boulot et vous
décidez pour commencer de remettre à
neuf une maison pour la revendre alors
vous avez du mal évidemment à
matérialiser vos idées évidemment
puisque vous êtes aveugle jusqu'au jour
où votre compagnon dessine sur votre
corps c'est extraordinaire c'est Prison
Break là il dessine sur votre corps ce
que vous ce qui voit quoi de façon à
vous mettre en contact avec ces maisons
à rénover on avait essayé plein de
différentes techniques et je sais pas
pourquoi tout d'un coup il a commencé
sur mon dos et mon dos ça marchait pas
vraiment et il a commencé donc sur sur
ma poitrine là sur le coeur en fin de
compte et et là tout d'un coup j'ai
vraiment ressenti j'ai vraiment compris
ce qui se passait et c'était la
meilleure technique et encore
aujourd'hui je n'utilise très très
souvent pour visualiser les choses et
vous commencez à faire des maisons et
vous devenez c'est le nom qu'on vous
donne aux États-Unis de Blind designer
c'est-à-dire l'architecte d'intérieur
aveugle c'est quand même extraordinaire
vous avez fait une maison qui a été
rachetée par Penélope Cruz en plus ça
m'a ça marche super bien vous avez
restauré un manoir dans lequel vivait
Coppola pendant le tournage du parrain
alors moi quand j'ai vu ça je lui dis
comment il peut faire enfin tout le
monde se dit mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut vivre cette vie designer quand on
est aveugle vous arpentez les pièces de
long large vous touchez tout vous
mémorisez les textures les calmes c'est
ça Eric toute pièce toute maison tout
matériaux les couleurs ont une énergie
je sais que c'est difficile de parler
d'énergie aux gens qui qui voient parce
que ils pensent qu'en fin de compte
c'est les yeux qui leur donnent toutes
les informations alors que c'est pas du
tout c'est pas du tout nouveau c'est pas
du tout vrai parce que vous mettez c'est
une expérience qui est dure à faire au
début mais vous mettez votre main sur
une certaine couleur vous avez certes
sentir une chaleur sur certaines
couleurs ou un certain froid ou il y
aura une réaction chimique qui se passe
ce qui est extraordinaire aussi c'est
que quand vous visitez une maison sur
laquelle vous allez travailler vous
guettez les courants d'air si vous
essayez de sentir les les flux d'air
j'utilise l'air par exemple pour pour
donner des odeurs agréables dans les
maisons parce que si l'odeur c'est quand
même des sens le plus importants chez
nous j'utilise vraiment tous les sens
que ça soit les odeurs que ce soit le
toucher que ça soit que ça soit les sons
parce que les sens sont très importants
les matériaux que je veux utiliser le
soleil aussi c'est que vous vous mettez
à certains endroits vous captez le
soleil qui arrive à cet endroit là et ça
vous aide dans votre travail
d'architectes et d'intérieur ça m'aide
pour beaucoup de choses ça m'aide pour
le placement
placement de certains meubles ça m'aide
pour le décider le genre de comment
d'atmosphère parce que le soleil va
changer l'atmosphère d'une pièce moi je
trouve c'est un des trucs les plus
dingues que j'ai vu dans ma vie c'est
une blague designer ce qui est marrant
c'est que j'ai jamais pensé vraiment
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose c'est
quelque chose qui est devenu tellement
naturellement que pour moi ça a toujours
été normal c'est pas c'est pas étonnant
je suis aveugle mais je suis la vogue
spécial et aux États-Unis vous êtes une
star
avec ce livre alors vous dites mourir
était une solution apaisante apprendre à
vivre aveugle était beaucoup plus dur
oui en effet parce que quand on se
prépare à la mort ça devient surtout
quand on souffle quand on a des moments
tellement tellement durs comme j'ai
passé quand même j'étais plein de tuyaux
de
chimiothérapie de vomir je pouvais plus
rien manger
c'était l'horreur quoi c'était devenu un
calvaire de vivre donc la mort c'était
pour moi quelque chose d'attirant d'une
c'était
le soulagement total donc après quand on
m'a dit ben oui mais la surprise c'est
que tu vas pas mourir mais tu vas rester
vivant aveugle
en fin de compte ça ça a été plus dur
vous allez faire quoi Eric maintenant
alors aujourd'hui je crois que
d'être un peu le comment l'élève de la
vie j'ai envie peut-être de faire
partager le son que j'ai appris je
commence du coaching parce que j'ai
réalisé une chose aussi c'est que dans
le design c'est que souvent les gens qui
ont des problèmes dans le design c'est
parce qu'ils sont un peu coincés dans
leur vie
j'ai trouvé ça dans un shot de
télévision qui a très bien marché aux
États-Unis et en prenant en fin de
compte tout en faisant le design de leur
maison décoincer un peu où ils étaient
dans leur vie par mon expérience par
tout ce que j'ai appris aider les autres
c'est quand même assez génial quoi Eric
Zemmour vous qui êtes tellement
pessimiste quand vous le voyez là cela
va vous donner du courage quand même se
donner de l'espoir mais je ne suis pas
du tout pessimiste pour les individus je
suis pessimiste pour l'époque les
mouvements de société mais je suis pas
je sais que chaque individu peut trouver
en lui les ressources de l'être humain
quand on voit Eric brassangla c'est
extraordinaire il y a une expression qui
dit big girls and life
merci de votre témoignage merci beaucoup
Eric
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu